la disparition cette nuit d'un avion
dans la péninsule du kamtchatka à
l'extrême orient de la russie des
morceaux d'un antonoff 26 ont été
retrouvés par des secouristes à quelques
kilomètres à peine de l'aéroport où
devait atterrir l'appareil
l'hypothèse du crash ne fait plus de
doute tout comme l'espoir de retrouver
des survivants à bord 22 passagers et
six membres d'équipage la correspondance
à moscou de vera goffman il n'y aurait
aucun survivant dans le crash de l'avion
dans l'extrême orient russe les
autorités ont confirmé que l'avion à
bord duquel se trouvaient van deux
passagers et 6 membres d'équipage s'est
écrasé lors de son atterrissage dans la
région du kamtchatka il effectué la
liaison entre la ville de petropavlovsk
kamtchatski et la ville de pallanne à
une partie du fuselage est retrouvé sur
le versant de la colline petit bras tca
et la seconde se trouve en mer à 4 km de
la côte
les services de secours en fait savoir
que plusieurs bateaux et avait été
envoyé près de la zone supposée du crash
une enquête a été ouverte par les
autorités russes
il envisage plusieurs versions de
l'accident mauvaise météo
dysfonctionnements de l'avion ou erreur
de pilotage ou propose d'écouter les
autorités de la direction les enquêtes
d'extrême orient du comité dont kate sur
les transports de la fédération de
russie et ont engagé des poursuites
pénales sur la base criminelle de la
troisième partie de l'article 263 du
code pénal de la fédération de russie
concernant la perte de communication
avec l'avion à n 26 selon les données
préliminaires
ce 6 juillet 2021 dans la journée près
de la localité de pallanne à
dans le territoire duquel chaque tu as
la communication avec l'avion à m 26
avec passagers et l'équipage à son bord
a été interrompu les recherches de
l'avion disparu sont en cours l'équipe
d'enquêteurs se prépare à partir pour
effectuer une inspection des lieux
des enquêtes sont menées au sein de la
compagnie exploitant d'avions ont défini
le nombre de personnes à bord on mène
d'autres actions d' enquêtes et de
procédures visant à établir les
circonstances de l'incident
l' enquête criminelle se poursuit et
devenir dans un communiqué de presse
l'agencé fédérale de transport aérien a
fait savoir que les conditions
météorologiques ont été particulièrement
difficiles au moment de l'atterrissage
de l'appareil
elle a évoqué un brouillard de nuages
fragmenté et des nuages continuent à une
altitude de 720 m